epic files for a temporary restraining
order against apple
a new batman game reveal is imminent and
ghost of tsushima gets a brand new free
co-op mode i'm lucy and these are the
biggest gaming news stories
for monday august 17th
it's getting ugly between epic and apple
or should i say uglier to catch you up
fortnite was removed from ios and
android platforms after
trying to circumvent apple and google's
store fee
epic is now suing apple and google over
anti-trust violations
arguing that the two companies operate
monopolies over their respective mobile
platforms
well now apple has informed epic that on
friday august 28th
all of epic's developer accounts will be
terminated
and that epic will be cut off from ios
and mac development tools
including those it uses to work on the
unreal engine
epic has now issued a new filing in
which it claims that apple has
retaliated
furiously to the lawsuit and notes that
apple has not indicated that the unreal
engine itself has violated any app store
policies
the filing states not content simply to
remove fortnite from the app store
apple is attacking epic's entire
business
in unrelated areas epic's injunction
looks to block apple from doing
three key things delisting fortnite from
the app store
taking adverse action against epic
including blocking access to the apple
developer program
and removing fortnite from existing
users devices
epic also argues that it would suffer
irreparable harm if apple were to cut
off
its developer program access like i said
it's getting really
ugly we'll keep you updated as things
progress
dc games are like buses you wait years
for one and then two come along at once
last week rocksteady revealed its new
game suicide squad kill the justice
league
and tomorrow it looks like the other
batman team wb montreal
is revealing another now we know that wb
montreal has a panel scheduled for
saturday as a part of the dc
fandom event but a countdown on their
official website ends at 8am pt
tomorrow morning their game is rumored
to be called gotham knights and is said
to take some story beats
from scott snyder's court of owl's run
it's been teased for
years at this point wb montreal tweeted
out a teaser
almost a year ago and snyder himself
quote retweeted it
with a reference to court of owls before
swiftly deleting we'll of course be
covering the countdown reveal as well as
the panel this weekend
so keep your eyes peeled to youtube.com
gamespot
surprise ghost of tsushima is getting a
new free co-op mode
legends is a separate mode that doesn't
follow the adventures of jin sakai and
his quest to defeat the mongols
it's only playable in co-op and as
described by developer sucker punch
is haunting and fantastical with
locations and enemies inspired by
japanese folk tales and mythology
and an emphasis on cooperative combat
and action
there'll be four different character
classes to choose from samurai hunter
ronin and assassin
each with their own unique abilities if
you play as a pair you can undertake a
series of co-op story missions
or if you play as a four take on
wave-based survival missions including
brand new only enemies
with supernatural abilities a
four-player raid will also be available
which will take you to an
entirely new realm and it'll be coming
out shortly after launch
well fair to say we didn't see this one
coming but i for one am stoked to jump
back
into gosu tsushima when legends launches
later this year
you've got a couple of weeks to grab
your play for all merch from the
gamespot store with all of the proceeds
going towards black lives matter
as well as covert relief thank you for
watching today's episode of save state
chastity will be with you tomorrow you
can find me on twitter at lucy james
games and i'll see you soon
[Music]
you